hey guys I'm Ryan and I'm Jerry
and here it is people people like China
one two three four five organ I uh
whatever the [ __ ] your name is depending
like prototype guy a few other people oh
I can't really remember right now but a
lot of people at least 160 have asked us
to do the raid redemption review and
here it is people our first DVD review
coming your way coming your way you guys
have really been demanding like every
good because you guys are wasting my
time I haven't heard a single negative
reaction is okay good
every other day I log on and then
someone's like when you got to do the
raid review you get you guys actually
like get mad at us we're here how to
peer pressure now doing this for you
guys we better be good
you ready Jerry I suppose you ready
Sally all right hands in people hands in
hands in one two Zuri's irate Redemption
one two three the r8 redemption I like
to spit on your face and I like it when
you spit online it's so hot Wow
so we just finished the raid redemption
Holy Mother of [ __ ] gods that movie
was [ __ ] banana bizarre it crazy I
usually hate movies like that that are
non-stop action but this is movie had
some of the best fighting scenes I've
ever seen like ever and I've seen a lot
of like I've seen a lot of foreign films
that are action based and damn dude
first off there's a lot of really unique
kills in this film that are very Wilson
yeah door one oh sorry
just throw need sweeps him off his feet
and then he just like weigh-ins right on
the crack to door oh my god
yeah I'm like when people got hit like
it really it wasn't like a fight scene a
lot of the time where it's like people
are just getting hit whatever at one
point when what's the guy's name
Raja Rama Rama when Rama and his brother
are fighting that one short Asian dude
agent Andy are fighting man
Mad Dog yeah and when they're fighting
that dude and like at one point Rama's
just like like you know like Mortal
Kombat like very tell some people get
hidden stuff like you can feed the way
their performances are is just like whoa
we're really getting hurt right now what
everything's really really fast you feel
the impact yeah all those hits I mean a
lot of American action films they get me
angry because you can totally tell that
they're not even touching the person
that it's like and it's really slow
action or you can tell that they did it
slow and then just like sped it up but
this looked like it was just constant
constant constant like they were
actually going out speed and it was oh
my the amount of control these actors
and these stuntmen must have had it's
just ridiculous I can't even fathom a
minute yeah the [ __ ] did they just all
take those hits like it's it looked like
they were all really getting hit yeah
all the time
yeah and especially the main guy man
like that guy's awesome he was really
cool yeah a lot of people have been
saying like oh this one doesn't have
story it's just an action film was
really gut-wrenching for me I connected
with it I felt a connection with the
main character right up front he has a
total performance in this movie that's
the cool thing too is all these actors
are not just badass they're all like
really good actors whoever said that
clearly has not I'm sorry but like most
action films the ad they don't have you
know any character development really or
they don't have a story backing it up
that makes you care about the characters
but I don't know what movie you were
watching because I certainly care at the
fact that he had a kid at home like that
wasn't even born yet and his wife said
he told he was gonna be back I mean you
may be single because if you went
through something like that it's not
just nothing it's a very simple film
it's it is an action movie I mean really
it is an action movie and it's not heavy
on story by any stretch of the
imagination think it gives you it gives
you enough to care about these people
and feel like you know there's a lot at
stake in that moment like it doesn't get
overly telegraphing it's like if you if
you think about the situation there and
they're working their way to the top of
this building you get the amount of
information it makes sense to get yeah
at first it's scary to what how is it
like it gives the actors have such a
great job with with the fear their
feeling and everything like that
was really well done in a [ __ ] way it
was just like captured was beautiful why
it was yeah this isn't like one of the
best shot action films I've ever seen I
tog Rafi it's like how did they get that
camera to be in those places like that
one scene where they jump from like one
floor to the other and follows it
there's some cool gun action too like a
first it becomes mainly martial arts in
the first like I'd say like 3040 minutes
it's mainly gone actually like that it
wasn't too much of any of them yeah I
mean like I like that it wasn't just
fist fighting it wasn't just guns and it
wasn't just knives it was like all those
and then they include other things that
they compete them with like who knew a
light can flip someone's throat so well
yeah it's like it's a combination gun
fighting knife fighting hand to hand and
then just stuff that's around yeah
perfect like you wouldn't but I love to
is like the camera keeps the fighting
rolling it doesn't like it doesn't have
a bunch of crazy cuts the whole time
yeah I tell these actors like really had
choreographed meant when I was talking
about like American fighting to is that
they'll cut it right when they're about
to like hit the person like that's what
a lot of movies do now is that they'll
cut it like right when they're about to
hit and it's like really I've seen a
woman where you do not see one fist look
like it actually touched a person even
acting wise they would always cut it and
I was like this is so lame like anyone
can do that but this you could tell they
did just continue as take just the
camera was just going around and they
were just fighting and fighting and
fighting and that is that that is talent
right there well I don't even think it's
in American action lately it's the lack
of hits it's it's that we feel the need
now to make the camera shaky as possible
and to make as many cuts as possible
it's not even that people don't get hit
it's just so you can't tell a lot of the
time what is happening
ya know how can you forget the [ __ ]
music was awesome
it's Mike Shinoda from Linkin Park and
then with a guy named Joseph Stalin yeah
but no the music it does have a Lincoln
Park feel to it a little bit and yeah
you can hear those those especially the
the more cynthy textures they use is
good music and grit and like villains
too were scary yeah first time we see
the villain you just has people who
lined up and they just you train them I
mean they don't have like a big
backstory or anything it's just the way
they were yeah they're mysterious yeah
it makes up for not having a ton of
exposition that kind of backstory by
making the villain scary and hateable
yeah putting these people in a situation
where you can identify with them and
then building the stakes and the
suspense constant honestly when I first
saw them I was like they look like
nothing it's just the way it was done
that really made it ten times more scary
like this is this is the perfect example
of excellence in simplicity definitely
cuz it wasn't heavy on anything really
and I'm pissed that they're doing an
American remake like why this this is a
pretty popular foreign film they don't
need to remake this film
well that and and people enough people
compared it to dread that just let dread
be the American right and and and called
it so bad
thank you guys so much for pushing it on
us to watch this match
thank you guys like that is one of the
best films I've seen like yeah like I
love that when it comes to an action
genre that is one of the best by far
it definitely deserve all the awards you
deserve every war every recognition you
you guys again I can't wait for the ray
tube Bernard Ferrand Oh Baron dollar no
boom Randall I forgot what it means all
you guys have told me what it means I
forgot but yeah I'm psyched to see that
but ya know this was totally worth it
and I [ __ ] wish I saw it in the
theaters man yeah that would be one hell
of an experience one of the revival
houses around does a screening I I'm not
gonna say I'd say definitely own it
yeah series I as soon as I get some
money I'm gonna buy this movie buy it by
like three copies you can give it to
your friends yeah and while you're at it
why don't you subscribe to our channel
this button right up here right above
Sally click it you'll like it and you
know I'll put the button right below
Sally's neck here or around the chest
area that's her church channel her own
personal child oh thank you brothers you
know putting in I actually just uploaded
our video sorry yeah I just look
uploaded of an interview never never
hope you got that out you don't know how
to talk so I just finished editing and
uploading the second part - oh my god
part 2 - the interview I did of her yes
mm-hmm
that is really dude please check it out
so thank you guys so much
good niya I'm gonna dedicate this one to
you and prototype guy and a bunch of
your guys so every night I can't come to
the top of my head but thank you guys
are all been awesome and please
recommend more movies that are out on
DVD or Netflix for us to watch
definitely good ones like this I was
having a sweet moment I was not gonna
sweet when when - what's better than a
[ __ ] yeah yeah yeah I like doing
that's it oh I hope that's not a [ __ ] on
tumblr I made a girl on the phone -
dating tip she's my best friend me
actually did that hot you don't even
know actually she is but she a redhead -
no she black no she's been a Hispanic is
she a black redhead is she she's
Hispanic - chef big boobs yes okay they
have like the same size but she has like
really awesome bras that make him look
bigger you just revealed in C good job
she well cause she was like teaching me
how to make my boobs look bigger can you
show us much of jenna Marbles video for
that didn't you understand well thank
you guys oh it's on yeah oh my god